senator cruz and senator lee
down involving georgia so major league
baseball
the only sport i've ever liked
is alienating me as a fan
because major league baseball is
canceling the all-star game in
in georgia they're going to move that
all-star star game somewhere else why
because of georgia's awful terrible jim
crow
racist voter law that is still
more lenient than most at least many
states in the country including very
left-wing states
like new york new york has significantly
more restrictive voter laws
than georgia does now under the
republican bill
so is mlb are they going to move the
game to
to new york well that would be weird
wouldn't it that'd be awkward
they wouldn't even have to justify it
they wouldn't they would just do it
right because
georgia currently has a republican
governor
new york has a democrat governor
democrats
according to the their own logic the the
democrat state
is worse but it just doesn't matter i
mean don't forget
they hailed andrew cuomo as the great
kovid savior
he was the great hero of coronavirus he
was the worst governor in the country by
a longshot on coronavirus
committed crimes in his handling of
coronavirus
doesn't matter they won't answer for
that when they try to hold him
accountable because he's not looking
good on tv they'll just get him on some
other thing
they'll say he winked at his secretary
so probably it's not going to be a big
deal which is why republicans need to
exercise political power here cruz and
lee
are calling on the federal government
jeff duncan too who's a representative
and you know he's a republican in the
house of representatives
they want to strip the mlb of anti-trust
exemptions
that grant them immunity from federal
anti-monopoly laws
mike lee pointed out that mlb has
legal protections that other sports
leagues like the nfl and the nba
don't have so they should
lose those well but michael that's
you're only doing this because the mlb
went woke
yup that's true you you got it
well but michael that the left wields
government power
and we don't want to be like the left
uh don't we don't want to win we don't
want to be successful we don't want to
have a sophisticated understanding of
politics i don't want to wield
government power in the
the same way that the left is doing it
because i think the stuff that the left
is doing
is bad the stuff that government that
the left is wielding government power
for is bad but so i don't want to do
that i want to wield government power
for good stuff
like all politics comes down to
like republicans have done until very
very recently
like we all understood is the end of
government like the people gave us power
to do
goodness gracious i am so glad this is
sort of tangential to the point on the
mlb anti-trust protections i am so glad
that i canceled my mlb tv membership it
actually hurt me because it's the only
sport i like so i'd watch the yankees
and i cancelled it last year when mlb
said they were going to reverse the
letters and put blm on the pitcher's map
i said i'm out
i'm done i don't care i i paid for the
year i think or but there were some
issues with it and i think
i was able to save so i just i i don't
even care if i pay already paid for it i
was going i just
wrote to them i said cancel my
membership they canceled it i really
wanted to start it up again this year
but they keep up the nonsense they don't
get my money and that's that
they don't want my money they don't need
my money or they they don't want
a relationship with conservatives that's
fine
they don't there are limits here folks
i'm all for a very
broad realm where private companies can
do what they want and pursue their
interest i think that's great and i like
free markets and all that stuff
when a woke corporation like the mlb
tries to undermine election integrity in
my republic
that's too far then i've got to start
exercising my political power
and if you are still laboring under this
ridiculous shallow
pseudo-libertarian notion that cropped
up over the last 10 years that
private companies should be able to do
absolutely whatever they want including
betraying and undermining our polity i
can't help you okay if you still believe
well build your own twitter build your
own youtube
oh yeah mlb wants to undermine our
election system
that's fine it's a private company no
sorry buddy
that ain't conservative that ain't
conserving
nothing rand paul also called out
the mlb because he he gets this you know
there's two sides here
we always hear well we conservatives
need to act in the culture
and we focus too much on politics we
need to work in the culture actually we
don't focus on either and we need to
focus on both
we need yes we need to take personal
actions here cancel your mlb membership
don't go to the stupid hollywood movie
you don't want to support we also need
to take political actions
you do both at the same time and rand
paul tweeted out quote
your sports league might be a little too
woke if
it will freely do business with
communists in china and cuba
but boycott's a u.s state that wants
people to show an id to vote hashtag mlb
all-star game hashtag mlb
of course of course this is true i mean
you need to show an id to buy a beer at
yankee stadium
i know this because i was turned away
many times when i was 18
19 20 years old but you're not supposed
to show an id
to vote i i am beginning to think that
this is less
about left versus right and more about
i don't know call it nationalism versus
globalism
it's less about republicans versus
democrats and more about
america versus the liberal global regime
because yeah they're not going to call
out china joe biden's not going to do
anything here joe biden
pressured the mlb to leave georgia but
he's not going to pressure
any company not to support the olympics
this
this chinese showcase joe biden isn't
is barely going to say a harsh word
about china
because china is part of this
international
regime whereby we well they buy a lot of
our debt we got to we got to buy their
products they
they invest a lot and look it's fine
it's cool
we don't want to we can we can afford to
lose those troglodyte conservatives
but we can't afford to lose china so the
nba is not going to say anything about
china it's very big there
we're just not going to upset anything
just as long as we have global trade
that's all fine and we're all it's all
good and we support the un
and the who and the imf and the wto
that's really the political battle here
between competing political institutions
and competing
political loyalties if you enjoyed that
video be sure to hit the subscribe
button so everyone waiting through the
wasteland of youtube
knows that we've got the absolute top
content
out there
[Music]
you